welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of the Indian
and post-credits scenes for Blue Beetle
spoilers ahead audiences are leaving
this movie with a ton of questions like
what happened to Ted cord all these
characters gonna be part of the DCU
going forward did the alien Scarab
actually climb into Jaime's butt we will
attempt to answer two of those questions
here today a reminder that new rockstars
is three channels please subscribe to
all three the break room's gonna have a
great review of this movie and tag
Rapture has informed us that
entertainment journalists like us are
allowed to review movies like this we
support the actors and writers in their
strikes okay Blue Beetle tells the story
of aimless college grad Jaime Reyes
played by Joe Lamar duenia he's moving
back home from Gotham to palermis City a
fictional miami-inspired Locale created
for the film while on a job interview at
cord Industries he gets caught up in a
corporate Espionage plot and becomes the
host to an alien Scarab that grants him
a suit of armor in many different sizes
of swords and the ability to absolutely
annihilate buses Jaime and his family
become targets of Victoria Court played
by Susan Sarandon she's CEO of the mega
Corporation once led by her brother Ted
cord before he mysteriously disappeared
she's after the script to create a new
source of green energy just asking she's
making super soldiers they this is a
comic book movie so it's always going to
be super soldiers right also looking for
the Scarab it's Ted's daughter Jenny
cord she wants to save her father's
Legacy and maybe smooch with Jaime
during a raid that kills Jaime's father
he is taking a Victoria's compound where
the plan is to kill him get the Scarab
and put its power into car packs a
Bruiser a few words who takes occasional
long and glances at a locket Jaime's
family mounts a rescue operation using
Ted cord's old Tech they found in his
secret lair he has a secret lair because
he was formerly the Blue Beetle a
superhero that defended palermis City in
the 80s before disappearing while hooked
up to Victoria's debt machine Jaime
connects with his deceased father in the
spirit realm merges Consciousness with
the Scarab then wrecks shot while his
sister punches dudes with a modified
Nintendo power glove and his grandma
fires a chain gun while dropping hints
about her revolutionary past Jaime and
carpack's fight but Justice Jaime is
about to deliver the final blow the
Scarab shows and carpax's tragic pass as
a Child Soldier who is used manipulated
by Victoria I'm a spare scarpax who
grabs Victoria and self-destructs while
the Rey his family escapes we don't see
Victoria or car packs die but the
explosion is ridiculously huge so I'm
guessing they didn't survive but they
could always be back because comic book
movies after Jaime's dad's funeral Jenny
pledges to rebuild the Reyes destroyed
house Jaime's uncle gets a sweet new
product Place Toyota Tacoma and Jenny
and Jaime do some long-awaited smooching
finally the two of them Blast Off
probably destroy more buses in our
mid-credits scene we see the cord
mansion and move into Ted's Blue Beetle
Lair one of his mini screens glitches
out and we see a megapixelated version
of Ted cord it turns out when Jaime's
Uncle Rudy turn on Ted's computer it
sent him some kind of single Ted is
pleading for someone to find Jenny and
tell her that he's alive no actors
listed for this voice Cameo and the only
other time we see Ted is a family
portrait painted in a conveniently
abstract style there were some rumors
that Jason Sudeikis was playing him but
those have been debunked as far as we
know no actor has been cast to play Ted
Court in any future DC projects the
post-credits scene is mainly for comedy
we see some scenes in the stop-motion
Spanish language cartoon for Jaime's
Uncle Rudy broadcasted into court
Industries during the raid the cartoon
is an homage to El chapula in Colorado
or the red Cricket a comedy superhero
that appeared on TV in the 70s in Latin
American countries a chapulin is really
an edible grasshopper so it's not that
intimidating but he is more agile than a
turtle stronger than a mouse and no blur
than a lettuce so where was Ted cord
transmitted from remember how old cell
phones were giant cumbersome bricks and
now we have nice Sleek ones that fit
easily in our pockets well wallets are
the same way so say goodbye to your
bulky wallet of yesteryear and say hello
to ridge ridge has reinvented the wallet
and it is a massive improvement over the
ginormous overstuffed wallets that we
all grew up with the ridge wallet is
slim but expands to hold up to 12 cards
plus cash Ridge wallets come in over 30
colors and styles including carbon fiber
burnt titanium forged Ember and burnt
Damascus each wallet is built with RFID
blocking materials that protect your
info from digital pickpockets and adds
an optional air tag attachment so you'll
never lose your wallet again Ridge has
80 000 5 Star reviews and each wallet
comes with a lifetime warranty the rich
team is so confident that you'll like
your wallet that they'll let you test
drive it for 99 days and if you don't
love it send it back for a full refund
and from now until it's September 30th
with every dollar spent on the website
before you'll be entered to win a brand
new upgraded Ford Bronco or if you
prefer cash you could take 75 000
instead the winner will be announced in
October enter for your chance to win and
get 10 bonus entries by going to MyLink
ridge.com new rockstars and use my code
new rockstars for 10 off your order
we've seen the DCU Multiverse break open
in the flash so it's possible that he
traveled to one of the realities we saw
in that movie my guess is that he's
stuck in another time in the comics the
Ted cord Blue Beetle is best bros
teammates with Booster Gold Booster Gold
was a football star in the 25th Century
who hit rock bottom when he got involved
in some shady gambling then he got his
hand on some Advanced Tech most
prominently an AI robot named Skeets and
traveled back to the 20th century where
he became a hero and member of the
Justice League International booster and
Ted bro down became Repo Men owned a
casino and in the recent Blue and Gold
Series became social media stars for
live streaming their crime fighting they
also have on a number of occasions
traveled through time and mess crap up
the director has said in interviews that
they considered Booster Gold cameo in
their post credit scene but they ended
up just going with the scrambled chord
message instead head Booster Gold Series
has been announced as part of James
Gunn's new DCU so it would make sense
that Ted cord would be part of that
Series in some way no casting has been
announced for that show for the longest
time fans were theorizing that Nathan
Fillion had the right combination of
square jawed hunkiness and comedy shots
to play booster he's actually going to
be playing another one of DC's ego
driven himbos Lantern Guy Gardner in the
upcoming Superman Legacy it's not a long
shot to think that Beetle and booster
got lost in the time stream somehow and
are just trying to find their way back
if you have some guesses about Ted's
whereabouts let us know in the comments
speaking of James Gunn's new DCU is this
movie Blue Beetle part of it or is it
part of the Snyder verse or is it some
other pocket of the Multiverse Batman
Superman and the Flash are all mentioned
in the movie but none of them are
explicitly shown so we don't really know
what versions of them the characters are
referring to is there Batman Ben Affleck
or batinson or Michael Keaton this movie
was originally supposed to debut on Max
after the scrapped Batgirl where Michael
Keaton would be playing Batman so maybe
that was supposed to take place in the
Keaton bat Universe 89 the director has
said that the original cut of the movie
was about half an hour longer so that
might have included some specific
references to Batgirl that were cut when
that movie was scrapped James gonna say
on social media that Joe and martinia
will be part of the DCU moving forward
that's kind of the vague answer we've
been getting about who will and who
won't be part of the DCU moving forward
the most obvious answer is that probably
they're waiting to see what connects
with audiences if blue Beetle's a hit
they'll definitely pump out sequels that
shuttle the characters around to cameo
in other movies and streaming shows it's
not a hit that involvement will probably
be more minor as far as the Blue Beetle
film goes this movie was just so much
fun and it's tons of heart so I hope
that we see not only Jaime Reyes again
but his warm and hilarious family in
some form or another again please
subscribe to all three channels on our
Network you can follow me at eavos
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time bye
[Music]
foreign